knopf
el presidente joe biden dice no más a
los tiroteos en eeuu y busca que el
congreso reaccione y cambien las
políticas
tenemos que prohibir las armas de asalto
y los cargadores de alta capacidad si no
podemos prohibir las armas de asalto
entonces debemos elevar la edad para
comprarlas de 18 a 21 años y abordar la
crisis de salud mental profundizar en el
trauma de la violencia con armas de
fuego y como consecuencia de esa
violencia son medidas racionales y de
sentido común o comisiones más
demócratas en el comité judicial de la
cámara de representantes- promovieron un
debate con el fin de endurecer las leyes
nacionales y
usted dice que es demasiado pronto para
tomar medidas que estamos politizando
estas tragedias para promulgar nuevas
políticas uy irse pasado 23 años desde
columbine 15 años desde virginia tech 10
años desde sandy hook rangers extendido
demasiado pronto amigos míos qué
demonios están esperando el ifo pero en
el legislativo los republicanos ven
cualquier intento de regular la ley como
amenaza a la segunda enmienda un
representante que participaba en el
debate dejó en claro lo que piensa sobre
las armas no espero que esa arma no esté
cargada estudio en mi casa y puedo hacer
lo que yo quiera con mis armas y
mientras la polarización continúa los
tiroteos no cesan este jueves en racine
wisconsin en medio de un funeral hubo
otro ataque en chicago la ciudad vivió
su fin de semana más violento en 5 años
que dejó más de 50 personas baleadas en
diferentes hechos y nueve muertos y en
nueva york como una marcha donde niños y
jóvenes salieron a las calles en el mes
que busca generar conciencia sobre las
armas de fuego para pedir el fin de su
uso